now then too few teachers are being
trained in how to teach about the
Holocaust that's the finding of a new
report from MPs
which says the government should step in
to make sure education about the
genocide does not become patchy it says
well earlier this month the education
secretary said learning about the
atrocities can help protect children
against extremism while I'm joined now
by the government's special envoy on
post-holocaust issue sir Eric Pickles he
was of course the community secretary
until last May a very good morning to
you Eric no one would have thought I you
know not looking into this in detail
with the let's say even the you know the
amount of stuff that's on television
school trips to to the camps that this
still is quite a pertinent issue but the
report's thinks otherwise it's very much
a pertinent issue and I suspect the
amount of Holocaust education that kids
are getting now are more than what you
or I received women were at school I
gave evidence to this particular inquiry
but don't pick like the but UCL have
done some terrific research and do a lot
of work in terms of getting a teachers
up to speed and understanding a lot of
this is taught sometimes in history
sometimes in in religious education
sometimes in citizenship so it is
important particularly now this decade
where people who actually were
eyewitnesses to these atrocities by the
nature of things are going to be no
longer with us but the importance is of
course not just in remembering it's
about the lessons for today forces in
society forces in the world some of them
complete the genocide
well absolutely you would have thought
that this would have been a big game
changer but as time goes on there are
those who deny it there are those who
deny other Holocaust last year was a
20th anniversary the murder of all those
Muslims in Sherman Itza I put out an
innocent tweet I was absolutely mobbed
by people who say it didn't happen it
wasn't a case and if there is any that's
well documented it's that and he is very
important because this was the full plan
appeal of the state
systematically working out the murder of
Jews of gay people of those of Roma
extraction of people on the left of
politics and it was a systematic process
of stripping them of their property
stripping them of their dignity getting
rid of them and trying to pretend they
didn't exist one one aspect of it and
you know let's bring it up to the
present day we've been discussing it
this morning so far was of course that
the Kindertransport the young Jews that
were were taken in by the United Kingdom
and and other countries to save them
from those atrocities we're hearing
today that the government the Prime
Minister has been pressured to take
3,000 children from Syria from
Afghanistan and that an announcement is
is imminent on this I don't know if that
is a true or not I certainly did stand
up in the House of Commons in the summer
and suggest we might consider this I
think it is important you know that we
really don't get too far away from the
reality of the kindred that transport it
was fundamentally different the last
hint Kindertransport set off the
beginning of September 1939 and was
stopped and of the children on that
train I think only two survived the rest
went to the death camps and were
liquidated it's a similar kind it's a
social problem but let's not get too
close in in drawing the analogy that
parallels but it's not the same thing
though I am personally very sympathetic
to the idea of unaccompanied children
are children involved that's as far as
we'll go with the parallel but
nevertheless you'll personally
sympathetic to that and that would be on
top of the 20,000 people were taking
from the camp well it's under pronounce
the Commons and say exactly that and
that is my dream is my view okay another
lesson from history I was interested to
see you talking just the other day about
an incident that took place it was it
sent to st. Mary's College in in London
when there was there was an attempt to
have a meeting there at peace absolutely
enough and it was attacked and you drew
parallels with crystal Mac well I think
it's just unfortunate you know you've
got a situation where a bunch of people
were gathered they were listening to a
speaker who
wanted to talk about how peace was going
to be possible in the Middle East and a
bunch of Palestinian activists come in
smash there were in a smash glass it
just seemed to me if there's one thing
you shouldn't do in anti-jewish protests
is smash glass it's just ludicrous
very but tell us wider issues about
feeding to that debate about
particularly university campuses who is
and isn't allowed to speak yeah well I
think it is important that Muslim
students aren't Jewish students and
people from different religions should
feel absolutely safe in and in that
environment and there is a degree of
antis ISM anti-semitism on the rise and
there's a dreadful business where people
are conflating being Jewish with with
israeli foreign policy and expecting
jewish people to be responsible for for
what israel's doing now you're writing
in the Sun on Sunday today about about
the European Union and make it very
clear you want no particular friend of
the European Union but you're on the
prime-minister side clearly in terms of
the negotiations but you say hatred of
the EU and love of Britain are not the
same thing you pretty much do hate the
EU but Britain should vote anyway to
stay well I'm a massive fan and you know
I don't think when I arrived in Brussels
or not lots of Eurocrats saying Whoopie
Eric's arrived but the truth is of you
know a lot of friends and the opposite
camp but what I really want to know what
I want to know would we be materially
better off outside and nobody's produced
a shred of evidence to suggest I think
it would be a very risky thing I think
the Prime Minister is right to get the
reforms on what he does and if he
succeeds if the total package is there
that I'll be right with him but do you
think that attitude and it said cold
hard look at the financial and economic
facts as you say they're almost cynical
perhaps from the UK's point of view
might be termed from some of our our
European partners at the moment do you
think that is a good negotiating
strategy in that the people are going to
ask for concessions from we're going to
say you just in it for yourselves well
I'm a great believer in Britain
great believer in doing things that are
good for the United Kingdom and I think
this is there are a lot of people in the
European Union who think similar that it
will be a good thing for the the
Commission to be less ambitious in terms
of a superset I think it's important to
understand that are going to be
currencies inside the European Union
that are not in the in the euro and we
need to have a proper balance and
understanding that we don't want ever
closer Union but in terms of the of the
single market in terms of all things
that goes with that we will be
tremendously effective by outside and I
think it's better to have some control
inside than to go out providing the
prime minister comes back okay there's
that provider but how do you think Sir
Eric the Prime Minister is handling the
party management we all know we've
talked many times in the past about the
damage that it can be caused in the
risks within the Conservative Party
about Europe going back so far but this
report on the front page of The Sunday
Telegraph today saying that around about
40 Conservative MPs want to go and make
their feelings known to the prime
minister he's refusing to seen them see
them and the report says he's back to
his flashman self he's arrogant
well the Prime Minister can organise his
own diary doesn't need my advice - - but
I think it is fair to say there are a
number of folks who've made their mind
up and it wouldn't matter what the Prime
Minister came back with the wouldn't
regardless has been adequate what I
think is very important is after the
election that we all come together there
are really good friends of mine who old
completely opposite opinions they're
good conservatives there are things we
need to do for this country so the
important thing is we'll have a
referendum the people will be able to
decide and what the people decide is
we're all going to accept and what a
CEREC decided just to be crystal clear
about this you're more or less saying
well if the Prime Minister gets more or
less what he wants I mean yeah I think
that's a fairly reasonable he's offered
a package of measures I look very
carefully at the package of measures is
he's got a good track record it was one
the first two to offer effective veto
he's managed to bring things
so back he's been a good negotiator I
work with in closely for now on ten
years and I know he's a guy a little
delivery you I mean you hearing it's
more less in the back
oh no I'm five knots I have no idea I'm
just a voter okay hey well yeah bit more
than that so it becomes very good see
thank you very much indeed